check me out I'm a man I do what I want  go where I want I have the right to vote  I can legally own property what are they  so afraid of maybe they're scared that  if they teach us how the world works  we'll figure out how to take over of  course she's insane she's Emily  Dickinson oh yeah I'm a real catch you  need to cut out these sort of antics are  you getting married I have one purpose  and that was to become a great writer  because I could not stop for death he  kindly stopped for me  nice to see you Emily I realized without  you I might as well not exist and you  really are my favorite person when they  would beat it what I'm gone mmm-hmm  when you're dead dude no I mean like  when I'm in the other room oh I do not  approve of a woman seeking to build  herself there's nothing you can do to  stop me  [Music]  give me a great poet  the wolf will never forget  you  [Music]  you